Kevin Bacon I need to know what type of
prep goes into playing yourself
64 years of living
that's that's the research yeah yeah I I
have to say that it's
this is a strange thing to say but even
when I'm playing myself I don't feel
like I'm actually playing myself I feel
like I'm playing a character because
it's that somebody else's
imagining of who I am and what my life
must be like and the things that I care
about and the clothes that I wear and
the way my house would look so I still
feel like I'm kind of stepping into a
character in a strange kind of way yeah
would you show up in the future as
yourself in any Marvel movies
uh if if Marvel would have me I would uh
I don't know I you know I'm certainly
not opposed to the idea
so who in your family is the most
excited to see you play yourself
oh uh I don't know that anybody in my
family is so excited about that
uh I don't know I guess probably
probably Kira you know my kids don't
really look at a lot of stuff that I do
so I I maybe they'll watch the special
but I don't know they're they're grown
now and uh
um yeah I guess probably my wife yeah
if you had to choose who is your
favorite Guardian of the Galaxy
oh wow that's a really tough one I
wouldn't I mean one of the things that's
so amazing about the Guardians is
that they're all so appealing in their
own ways they're just all
so like different and fascinating and
um I don't know I mean I guess if I yeah
I think that I think the most unusual
character is group just because it I
mean think about it look at that like
what what is what's what is the mind
that comes up with with with that you
know the top tree that only says one
thing and yet you know everything and
it's you know it's just it's just such a
it's so crazy and and cool and and weird
I love it well we know Groot loves to
dance and we know that you dance as well
so who would win in a dance-off
oh I would say it would be the tree
hands down
okay okay very cool and then lastly I
know that you're going to be working
with or you might have already worked
with them Eddie Murphy in the Beverly
Hills Cop film
um what was that like seeing Eddie go
back to that role awesome great
fantastic
um you know
obviously that was such an iconic movie
and such a fun idea to bring everybody
back
um I'm the new guy you know I'm I'm the
old new guy so uh so I had I had a great
time making it awesome thanks for your
time Kevin